next we have the nominees in best
country duo or group performance chasing
after you by ryan hurd and man morris i
gotta congratulate you on the grammy
nominations best country song and best
country duo or group performance for
your collaboration with ryan how does
that feel that must feel pretty cool my
husband being nominated for the first
time for a grammy is so huge and getting
to share that with him i mean it's just
such a first like it'll always be such a
memory for us
[Music]
nothing will really compare to
the year that we had with that song
chasing after you you know just being on
a song together so a grammy nom is just
a bonus what was it like for you
recording and releasing an album with a
little one a brand new little one i was
just focused on like getting to know my
son and so i wasn't thinking about
writing songs for several months i'm a
dad too so i i love getting into like
kid talk he's obsessed with animals
turns two so we're having a little
petting zoo because he he's in such an
animal phase right now
yes life is good for the country star
who just released her third studio album
humble quest
writing this album was
i just didn't really have anything to
prove
this time around
and i could just feel light and free i
want to do something real quick with you
we do a little thing called country star
confessions you ready yeah better life
who's your dream collaborator beyonce
we're two two texas girls and i just
love that she can sing literally
anything her heart desires what is the
habit of quirk that drives your friends
or significant other nuts i'm really bad
at responding to texts who is the most
famous person in your phone what was the
last thing you texted them about maybe
like
cheryl crowe who was just texting me
about circles around this town and
saying that she loved it and super sweet
so
i love you cheryl
[Music]